so big sur has been out for apple
products for a little while now
today we're talking about archicad 24
and big sur
is it time to upgrade or should you wait
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today like i previously mentioned we're
talking about big sur
and we're talking about archicad 24. to
give you a point of reference everything
we're talking about today
was generated on a late 2015 imac
it was previously upgraded from catalina
to big sur
and has been completely wiped starting
fresh
archicad 24 has also been updated with
every single hotfix
and all the plugins have been applied
we're running a usb
key dongle that directly plugs into the
back of the imac
all the files are downloaded directly
off the cloud
saved onto the desktop for practicality
and to be able to run the tests in the
same way so let's start by talking about
speed everybody's been talking that the
big sur has been a great performance
boost for all
macs regardless of what product you have
and how old it is
apparently it has been a good
performance jump across the board
so i genuinely wanted to test this
before i upgraded to big sur
the test was very simple download an
archicad file
open it up and see how long it takes for
archicad
to start loading and to be able to
actually use it
i don't know about you guys but every
single time i load archicad
it takes a pretty decent amount of time
so i wanted to test this on catalina and
then again
on big sur when it was fully upgraded so
there isn't an overly technical way of
doing this
except by breaking down the loading
stages in phases
i tested the speed and performance in
three loading stages
it was a very simple test if you've ever
used archicad on a mac before
you'll know all of these phases very
very well
so the first phase was clicking on the
archicad file
and opening it up with arcade 24. the
logo at the bottom of the dock would
start bouncing
and the end of that phase would be when
the archicad 24 logo
appeared on the screen that second phase
would then
end when archicad would actually open
and begin its processing of all the
libraries and parts
and finally that third phase would end
when archicad was actually usable
so i performed this over a number of
times every time shutting down the imac
loading it back up again and repeating
the test from a fresh
reboot i wanted the test to be fair to
be exactly the same and for there'd be
no cached memory
so i deleted the cache every time as
well now the speeds on catalina
were relatively okay personally speaking
we had an overall load time of two
minutes
and six seconds it was broken down into
those three phases
one bounce which took 24 seconds and
99 milliseconds the 24 arcade logo
took a minute and 35 seconds and one
millisecond to disappear
and the load time took 31 seconds and
42 milliseconds to actually be usable
overall two minutes and six seconds this
test was performed five
times and those numbers are an average
of those five test results
once i upgraded to big sur i repeated
these tests and the numbers were
actually
really good so not to give anything too
quickly away
but the numbers came in at two minutes
and three seconds
versus two minutes and six seconds the
overall performance boost isn't
huge but having just that small
comparison there
is enough to break it down further if
you're interested where those
performance changes occurred
it took 21 seconds and 77 milliseconds
for the bounce to stop it took a minute
and seven seconds and 94 milliseconds
for the 24 logo to disappear
and an additional 33.67 seconds
for archicad to be usable so now we know
that archicad 24
loads better but are there any bugs that
we should be worried about are there any
major glitches that are going to cause
concern well for the last week i've used
it for 10 hours a day
every single day at minimum two of those
days i used it for 14 hours a day
and without having to jump to the end of
the video
there was no major issues there were a
couple issues that i will talk about in
a second
but overall there was no major crashes
there was no major stalls
it was not a problem whatsoever so if
you're looking to upgrade to big sur
then there's actually no genuine reason
to wait from my experience of working on
arcade 24 with
big sur for the last week there has been
no major issues
that have caused me to regret my
decision however like i said a minute
ago
there are a couple small minor bugs that
you notice here and there
first of all the graphics are a little
bit all over the shop
and they're not uniform whatsoever big
sur has implemented that
ipad style graphics and is really
pushing that through
in the max when you load up arcade 24
and use any native archicad
elements you get those new ipad style
graphics
however when you use some plugins that
aren't native to archicad you're going
to see
some graphical discrepancies the main
ones are very obvious and they're not a
big deal you can really work around them
when using a random plugin for me it was
a 4d library
every time i opened up the settings and
looked through them
everything seemed okay except when i
went to exit out the exit cross was a
little bit
squished and disproportional but again
not a big deal the button still worked
absolutely fine secondly you just start
to get
thrown off by the different graphics
you'll open up one window it'll look
like one thing you'll open up another
window it'll look completely different
and you don't know where to click
so it's more of just a inconsistency
in the ui that hasn't been updated 100
however from a technical aspect and from
it working productively
absolutely no issues anyway that's all
for me today guys thanks so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video if
you did
make sure you smash that like button if
you want to see more of my content
make sure you smash that subscribe
button and as always i will see you
next monday